so I I thought you got the best sense
that Politics as normal have been
suspended today uh we weren't expecting
we didn't have any advanced notice that
the visit from president zelenski was
going to take place this morning we
didn't know one was on the cards and yet
it is completely dominated the news
agenda uh really there are going to be
any two stories all the way through the
day on the news and one is what's
happening in turkey and Syria and the
other is uh the visit by president
zielinski now at moment of kind of where
the world Spotlight sort of the domestic
Spotlight and the world is looking at
the UK Parliament at the House of
Commons it it could feel that people
rise to the occasion
today was a lot of people just getting
in on the ACT I'm afraid if I'm being
completely brutal
um there were lots of people making lots
of points I'm not sure that we learned
anything I'm not sure that that we shed
much light
um on on anything uh what you did have
was a sense that everybody was on the
same page uh there were no dissenting
voices when it comes to Britain standing
steadfast uh with its Ukrainian allies
and although president zielinski wasn't
in the viewing Gallery as perhaps he
might have might have been he's
preparing for that one o'clock statement
in Westminster Hall which is
a few meters away uh to both houses of
Parliament uh you didn't get any any
sign of dissent and uh the opposition
labor party and the kirstama made it
quite clear that they would uh be
standing taking pretty much the same
position that Rishi sunak has has done
uh which is the same positions list same
position uh as um Boris Johnson
um but then beyond that it was a it was
a session that's that basically saw a
lot of people trying to come up with new
angles sort of on the on the same you
know on this on the same thing and and
and and and gently trying to underscore
their own domestic political position
um if you look at que estarma's
calculation tonight
um I think that he decided he will have
decided that he wanted to use all of his
six question allocation on this because
one of the goals I think at the moment
for the labor leadership is to
underscore their hope that people start
to see kiss time and not just as a
domestic figure but as a global
Statesman and that was one of the things
behind that trip at the end of January
to Davos so you could see kiss Dumber on
the world stage
hanging out with fellow global leaders
even though he's a he's an opposition
party figure and I think that by being
able to
effectively concentrate today just on
this one Global International Affairs
international relations topic he he
looks he he looks to to do that again
um uh they hope that that has some
beneficial effect and also cynically uh
there isn't going to be anything else on
the news all the way through the day so
there's no point in making party
political uh attacks they'd seem to fall
on deaf ears um when uh when the other
leaders and the other MPS and pmqs uh
made them but then but then he sort of
danced around the houses he wanted to
underscore uh Labor's commitment to Nato
it's sort of making a domestic political
Point
um uh he he also talked about uh what
victory will rather defeat for President
Putin would look like and and here I
think you get quite quickly into the
into the to a gray and uncomfortable
area not that anyone really actually
wanted to debate the difficult bits of
the Ukraine crisis in the Commons
chamber today because he asked um
uh uh do we have to keep going until
President Putin accepts defeat given
that President Putin keeps on coming
back for more but but in asking that
question he sort of highlighted that
it's it's unclear what victory looks
like does it involve President Putin
still being in office or if as Kirsten
argues he is Dylan office won't he come
back for more but of course uh president
staying in office in Moscow is not a
subject that I think that UK politicians
would want to pronounce on and make that
a hurdle uh for victory or a goal
because of the possible uh incendiary
consequences that that kind of position
uh would have
um similarly talking about things like
reparations having to fall to Russia for
what's happened happened in in Ukraine
is sort of dancing around and a a sort
of area that's that's theoretical but
sounds good to the average punters the
average uh to the average
um voter so I think that there was uh
and then by the time we got to Vicki
Ford dressed in Ukrainian is asking
whether or not there's been a minute
silence for Ukraine I think that that
rather summed up I thought that some of
the tone of bits of bits of today
um uh so in a situation where the House
of Commons is United I don't think that
we learned a great deal other than
sending a strong signal of support in of
itself important ahead of President
zielinski's
address but not one where politicians
particularly stepped to stepped up and
took us uh uh uh beyond the kind of the
basics of what we already know